good morning everyone on behalf of Dean
Paul Cleary who regrettably is traveling
today let me welcome you to the Yale
School of Public Health centennial this
is a year long centennial celebration
and I encourage you by the way to take a
look at our website for all the
activities that are on being planned for
the year today's talk today's talk is
the fifth it's a fifth at our year-long
centennial Milbank
of public health in the 21st century's
flipped series the talk is given by our
visiting talk by a visit and a visit by
our distinguished guests the US Surgeon
General Vivek Murthy he is the fifth
this as I said the fifth which this
Milbank series actually was made
possible by a very generous the
generosity of the Milbank Memorial Fund
previous and future of Milbank lectures
are hosted by all the schools
departments thus ensuring a diverse
examination of our challenges and
opportunities for a broad spectrum of
distinguished leaders in their fields
today's lecture is hosted by our
Department of Health Policy and
management when CEA Winslow found at the
Yale School of Public Health in 1915 has
one of the first schools of public
health in the country he expanded the
way we think about the determinants of
health and he became actively involved
in improving the health in the city of
New Haven the state of Connecticut and
even globally Winslow's vision served as
a model for the creation of schools of
Public Health throughout the country and
we have a running argument with some of
our sister schools about which one was
the first at the scale School of Public
Health we have a very rich history of
extraordinary accomplishments in
advancing the science of Public Health
and educating leaders in their fields
and in translating our findings into
innovative approaches to a variety of
public health issues please continue to
join us throughout the year
as we honor in a myriad
ways Winslow's foresight as well as all
the Yale Public Health pioneers who have
paved a way for us gathering here today
and as we look ahead with the vision for
improved health for all in the next
hundred years innovation through
collaboration that that's the theme of
this centennial and the work conducted
in the Department of Health Policy in
management is an excellent example of
novel interdisciplinary approaches that
are needed to address the public health
concerns that we face on a global scale
speaking of interdisciplinary I'd like
to thank doctors Howie Forman and Zack
Cooper and the entire support team who
have made this extraordinary event
possible
dr. Forman is professor of diagnostic
radiology Public Health Management and
economics at Yale he is also director of
the MD MBA program at Yale faculty
director of the MBA for executives
leadership in health care and director
of the Yale School of Public Health
health care management program obviously
he does not have very much to do Zack
Cooper is an assistant professor of
public health and health policy and
economics at Yale he is also a resident
fellow at the school's institution for
social and behavioral studies social and
policy studies Zack will be moderating
the question and answer period today
after dr. knot thought Nothings talk
president solvei I'm sorry I am now
honored to introduce the president of
Yale University dr. Peter Salva to
welcome dr. Murthy
Peter sawblade president is the Chris
Argyris professor of psychology he
served as Provost at Yale from 2008 to
2013 before his appointment as president
in 2013 he received his PhD in
psychology from Yale as a member and as
a member of the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences and the Institute of
Medicine of the National Academies he
has received numerous awards and
honorary degrees his research in
wrists are lying the connection between
human emotion and health behavior the
School of Public Health is proud to say
that Peter holds a secondary appointment
as a professor in the department of
chronic disease epidemiology and the
Social and Behavioral Sciences Division
he has played key roles in two of our
major programs they are the center for
interdisciplinary research on AIDS and
the cancer prevention and control
research program we are equally honored
to count his wife Martha Moretti
among our alumni Martha received her NPH
here at Yale in the School of Public
Health and is now very active in local
and state public health organizations
and in her connections to our school
please join me now in welcoming
president Peter Sully
Thank You Bryan I appreciate that
introduction and welcome everybody it is
great to be here on this special
occasion and as you heard the school
Public Health has real emotional
connections for me and for Marta very
proud of being part of the faculty and
have lectured in this room before and
also that my lab back when it was going
strong was so connected to research
going on here in public health and many
collaborations across the connector from
the psychology department to the School
of Public Health the Milbank
lectures are just one of the many ways
in which one marking the centennial of
the School of Public Health and today
really is kind of a jewel in the crown
of this series it's not just a
tremendous honor to welcome the United
States Surgeon General back to our
campus but it's but it's also an honor
that we're welcoming him now there's a
trend he's been here multiple times and
we are welcoming him I'm not just
welcoming him but welcoming him back
before I tell you a little bit about him
I want to offer a few words of gratitude
to professors Howard Forman - Zachary
Cooper they really made today's session
possible and we really thank you for
setting up this extraordinary lecture so
thank you to Howie and to Zhang our
speaker dr. Murthy in a sense needs no
introduction I that is a cliche often
used when you have someone incredibly
distinguished speaking and I can only
tell you that it often doesn't work many
of you know that dr. Henry Kissinger
gave his papers to Yale University and
so he comes once or twice a year to give
a lecture on this campus and as
president I had the honor of introducing
him and I said well here is truly a man
who
needs no introduction and I hear this
pounding on the stage with a cane and
it's dr. Kissinger who's sitting on a
chair on the stage pounding his cane on
the stage and he looks over and he says
I don't do a very good Henry Kissinger
in the taste of it so try to use your
imagination
he says dr. president salivate I may be
a man who needs no introduction
but I am also a man who enjoys listening
to an introduction so now I still use
the phrase but it is meaningless
you know the Surgeon General is
America's doctor and he's responsible
for communicating health science
information to the public to overseeing
the US Public Health Service
commissioned Corps and in general to
protecting and advancing the health and
safety of Americans across this country
his interest in public health is rooted
in his earliest years when he spent time
in his father's Miami medical clinic he
earned his bachelor's degree from
Harvard and in 2003 his MD and his MBA
here at Yale completed his residency
training at Brigham and Women's Hospital
and Harvard Medical School where he
later joined it's faculty he has devoted
his life's work to improving public
health through service of clinical care
to research education entrepreneurship
and he describes I think you'll hear him
talk a little bit about it
his caring for patients has really a
great privilege in his life he
co-founded visions which is an hiv/aids
education program in India and in the
United States and the celestia project
which is a community health partnership
in rural India that trans women to be
health education providers he's also a
health care entrepreneur as I mentioned
and an innovator he co-founded and he
chaired trial networks which is a
software technology company that
supports research collaborate
and clinical trials he served as the
president of doctors for America a
nonprofit organization focused on
building high quality affordable health
care systems in his current appointment
he is working especially hard to build
cross sector sector partnerships that
address obesity that address tobacco
related diseases that reduced the stigma
associated with mental illness that
improve vaccination rates that establish
health prevention I was I'm sorry that
established prevention and health
promotion as the backbone of us
communities so last year I think many of
you know dr. Murthy was the speaker at
the School of Medicine's commencement
exercises for the class of 2014 and
we're very fortunate that he has made
the time in his schedule to rejoin us
here at Yale again this year but I have
to add something important because
something critical has happened between
these two speaking opportunities in his
life he he has not just had two speaking
engagements but he has and he has had an
engagement of a different kind
just last month last month he was
married to a fellow dr. Alice Chen who
also is connected to yell and to Moores
College in particular and I thought we
could take a moment and offer on behalf
of Yale University and the Yale School
of Public Health our heartfelt
congratulations on this new stage in
both of you
with that I am honored to welcome to
this stage our Milbank lecturer dr.
Vivek Murthy well thank you all so much
for that incredibly warm welcome thank
you president Sall avait for hosting us
here today
my thanks to associate dean leader and
to dr. Forman who is not only somebody
who helped bring this event together but
also a very dear mentor and personal
friend of mine who I've relied on for
counsel since I was first a student here
way back when so you know thank you all
for having me and I also just want to
say just how wonderful it is to be back
at you coming to Yale feels like coming
home in many ways and I was telling my
aide lieutenant Aneta who's here as well
that when we drove into New Haven last
night I felt this so I was like I felt
like a wave of ease just wash over me
because the memories I have here are
rich they're wonderful and I was really
blessed to be able to have some time
here now I spent five years here
shuttling between Cedar Street and
Hillhouse Avenue which was where the
Business School main campus used to be
before they got all big and fancy
but you know that that time we spent
learning in classrooms but it was also
spent meeting new people and exploring
ideas and I met lots of great people and
in fact only some of them held it
against me that I attended a certain
undergraduate institution in Cambridge
Massachusetts but generally people were
very welcoming they were very kind and
and they shared really of themselves and
it's for that reason that over time Yale
became more than a university but it
became a home to me it became a place
where people not only gave me ideas but
where they encouraged me and supported
me even when I doubted myself
and that has made all the difference in
my life so I will always be grateful to
Yale for that and always happy certainly
to come back but the real beauty and the
real power of Yale is in the fact that
each of us whether we're students or
faculty members has so many different
stories that we can tell it's the fact
that each of you who are here are here
for a reason and that reason isn't who
you are or where you're from or what
your parents may do for work but you're
here because you know that you are
capable of accomplishing something and
you know in your heart that big changes
have to happen to make health a resource
for every individual and every community
and you also know that you have to play
a role in making that a reality
when I was a student at Yale I had no
idea that I would become Surgeon General
many times I didn't even know what I was
doing the next day but what I did know
is that I was very lucky to be here
my father was supposed to be a farmer in
India he was the son of a rural farmer
in South India and for many years he
thought that's what he would do to just
to cultivate rice coconuts mangoes and
tamarind which is what they grew he was
never supposed to become a doctor and he
certainly wasn't supposed to move to the
United States and raise a family here
but just a few decades ago it's
conceivable that somebody who looked
like me could not have walked through
doors of opportunity in our country and
at this great university much less the
office of the Surgeon General but times
have changed thankfully for the better
and they've changed because of the hard
work and passion of so many leaders who
have come before
and today what I want to talk about is
how we collectively can keep that change
going in creating what I hope will be
the Golden Age of Public Health I want
to talk about how each of us can ensure
that public health is something that is
known by everyone regardless of where
they're there in the health sector or
not as a key foundation for our country
you and I know well that public health
is really more than just an isolated
field of study it's more than something
that sits in an ivory tower or at an
isolated you know Department of Public
Health desk
it really is in fact and this is
something I firmly believe health is the
fuel that powers everything in America
without health we can't succeed in
education we can't succeed in economic
development or in other fields of
endeavor every part of our society
therefore has a critical role to play in
improving public health but as public
health leaders it's our responsibility
it's our collective responsibility to
help the world understand this and in
addition to being experts in data and
analysis and in program development and
implementation you also must be
engineers who can build bridges between
various disciplines and fields of study
you must also be Masons if you will who
lay the foundations for collaboration
across sectors and you must be
translators who can help law makers and
physicians and business leaders and
educators develop a common language
around health that we can use to advance
it and I want to be clear I'm not just
talking about the work that you will do
in 10 years or 20 years or 30 years I'm
actually talking about the work that you
can do right now whether you're a
student or a faculty member beighton
this is because our country was really
founded on a radical idea radical at the
time and even sometimes radical now and
that's the idea that anyone regardless
of your background or country of origin
could contribute and could make a
difference in their own unique way that
fundamental value or set of values who
centered around fairness and equality an
opportunity have been at the center of
our country's best moments
and fighting over what those values
meant and who they apply to has also
been at the center of some of our
country's worst moments but today we
live in a unique moment in history at a
time when the combination of technology
and knowledge have come together with
breaking down barriers and this has made
it possible for more people than ever
before to play a role in improving the
health of their communities so that's
why I want us to come together to create
that Golden Age of public health it's a
time where different sectors can come
together and both recognize and embrace
embrace the role that they can play in
improving health but it can only happen
if we have leaders who articulate that
kind of vision for health because not
everyone understands it it can only
happen if we have leaders who can help
other sectors understand that even if
health is not in their title they still
have an important role to play in
improving the health of their community
this is the time where we need not just
establish leaders and experienced
professors but also young faculty and
young students to step up and be part of
this larger transformation in our
country and around the world and I say
to see you not just because you are some
of the brightest minds of our generation
that you are and that most of you know
already but I also say this because of
the great urgency that's facing our
country when it comes to public health
this is an urgency that I hear about
every day when I visit communities as
Surgeon General and I'll tell you about
some of them you know I hear from mayors
and doctors everywhere I go about how
the prescription opiate epidemic is
ravaging small towns and big cities
alike I hear from parents about how
addiction and mental illness are still
seen by too many as moral failings
rather than as chronic illnesses that
deserve and need to be treated I hear
from teachers who are trying to figure
out how to deal with a cigarette smiiing
used in their classrooms and I hear from
communities who are struggling with the
crippling epidemic of obesity that we
have that's affecting our kids and our
adults but most concerning to me is
something that dr. Salim and I spoke
about just a few minutes ago earlier
this morning what concerns me is this
sense that I get from many that they
have lost faith in their ability to
improve their health more and more when
I talk to people in communities big and
small I sense that they feel that forces
beyond their control are increasingly
determining their health forces related
to the food industry insurance companies
hospitals or other entities that have
clout in too many cases I feel we have
lost our agency when it comes to health
but there are also reasons to be hopeful
and I encounter these on the road each
and every day like young yes yesterday
for example I was in packing Las Vegas
and I met this wonderful family a mother
a father a daughter and a son who walked
to school 1.7 miles each way every day
and they do that because they know that
that's the way they can not only improve
health but they can also get some family
time you know I also draw hope from
programs that I encounter along the way
programs like the one I saw in Roanoke
Virginia where the community is coming
together to teach kids and parents alike
about fruits and vegetables and how to
use them to prepare healthy foods and I
also draw hope from programs like I just
visited in Indiana last week where law
enforcement and public health and
educators are coming together to build
strategies to address the opiate
epidemic which is taking its toll on
Indiana they are inspiring stories like
this that are dotted all across the
country and community is big and small
but our job as public health leaders to
ensure that these stories are more than
norm than the exception now I'm not
putting all of this responsibility on
you I promise I will share in that
responsibility and that is part and
really at the heart of the work that I
have been doing since I began as Surgeon
General last week for example we joined
in our office with nonprofit leaders and
private sector partners to launch our
call to action on walking and walkable
communities now you might initially
think about walking as a rather a dull
topic what does walking really have to
do with some of the complex challenges
we're facing but it turns out that
walking may end up being one of the most
powerful tools that we have for rolling
back the tide on chronic diseases like
diabetes and heart disease it also may
be part of rasa reclaiming the culture
of physical activity that we once had in
America now everyone in this room may
understand us but think about folks
outside this room you know at a time
when 3 out of 10 Americans live in
communities that don't have adequate
sidewalks at a time when chronic
illnesses like diabetes and heart
disease and cancer are responsible for 7
out of 10 deaths in America and for over
a trillion dollars in healthcare costs
at the time like this we have an
opportunity and I would even say a
responsibility to ensure that people
under the understand the facts about
walking in physical activity we have a
duty to ensure for example that they
know that just an average of 22 minutes
a day of moderate physical activity can
reduce your risk of heart disease and
diabetes and you can achieve this
through walking everywhere I have
traveled people have told me that they
were surprised at something so simple
something so fundamental like walking
that we've been doing for millennia can
have such a profound impact on one's
health but it's true and what's also
extraordinary is the diversity of
partners who came together and are
working now hand-in-hand to bring this
call to action to life partners who
include the National Collegiate Athletic
Association Johnson & Johnson and CEOs
of other companies the National Council
of shopping centers as well as Kaiser
Permanente people say it takes a village
to create better health and that's what
we're trying to reflect in our office
but we're also taking on other tough
challenges as well earlier this year I
worked on getting out into communities
to talk about the importance of
vaccinations about the importance of
ensuring that our vaccination rates are
high sometimes when we make major
breakthroughs we pull back and we assume
that we'll just keep going forward in a
positive direction and when we developed
meet a vaccinations like the measles
vaccine many people felt okay now we can
prevent those honest as the work is done
but as we saw in the measles at outbreak
that
that took place in the United States
starting in December of last year we
can't take our foot off the gas when it
comes to insuring that vaccination
vaccination rates are high because in
too many communities across the country
vaccination rates have fallen
dangerously low and that allows
illnesses like measles and others to set
foot in our country and to do damage
damage that could be avoided we're also
taking on additional issues as well at
the opiate addiction epidemic which I
mentioned as well as nutrition mental
health and emotional well-being and
we're seeking to engage a variety of
partners in this effort isn't think
creatively about how we do this and the
vaccination effort for example we teamed
up with Elmo to get the message out
about vaccinations both the children and
to parents
Elmo turns out as a remarkably effective
passenger and really quite spontaneous
he was a hysterical person I hope you
guys get to meet him someday
but we've actually done a few
collaborations with Elmo and what always
strikes me is that sometimes messengers
who we think speak to one audience
invariably end up speaking to a much
larger audience and I heard from any
parents afterward who told me that
parents who didn't have kids by the way
but you know hope to have kids Monday
but folks who said that they enjoyed
watching the video and it made them
rethink their stance on vaccinations so
that's good but what do all of these
initiatives
my goal is Surgeon General is to build a
culture of prevention in America a
culture that's firmly rooted in active
living in healthy nutrition and an
emotional well-being that's a culture
that our country deserves and it's a
culture that also demands that we
redefine what success means because too
often we see success only as treatment
done well or we see success as a model
that was proven to be successful or a
journal article that was submitted for
publication these are important but they
in and of themselves do not entirely
constitute success ultimate success
involves ensuring that our patients
never have to walk through the door of
our office or a hospital in the first
place that's real prevent
that's a community that's grounded in
prevention and I want us altima Lee to
be a nation that's as good at preventing
disease as we are at treating it that's
the kind of success that we should be
after now we face big challenges in the
end as a country these challenges aren't
new to all of you you are public health
professionals and you read about these
challenges every day and the headlines
of newspapers and all the airwaves but
never ever believe that these challenges
are bigger than the power of our
collective will because they are not and
if you ever doubt this just remember
that it was our collective will that
allowed a small band of colonists to
take on the largest empire at that time
in the world and to build a foundation
for what became one of the greatest
countries in civilization it was
collective will that also enabled our
nation to face down unspeakable violence
and racism and past the Civil Rights Act
back in the 1960s it was collective will
that allowed the public health community
and other communities across the country
and the world to ultimately launch a
campaign that eradicated smallpox a feat
that few thought possible at the time
that is the power of collective will and
the question that lies before all of us
today is what kind of country do we want
to build what kind of world do we want
to create with this collective will let
us create a nation where every man woman
and child has a fair shot at good health
let us create a nation that opens doors
of opportunity to all children not just
those born in the right neighborhoods
but also those who come to the United
States from distant shores and those who
also live in the Forgotten corners of
our country let us create a nation where
health is seen clearly for what it is as
the foundation that makes everything
else possible the most valuable asset
that our nation possesses the world
needs all of you leaders in public
health who have dedicated your lives to
making the country better
the world needs you to step up and to
make this vision a reality
and I am proud to say that as your
Surgeon General and as a proud alum of
Yale that it will be my pleasure and
privilege to stand shoulder-to-shoulder
with you as we seek to create this
vision together thank you so much
thank you for for coming and and more
than that thank you for sketching out a
vision of public health I think we
should thank Howie
not just for for having here but but
also for what you do for the students so
when I open this up for questions and
I'm gonna sort of start one out so -
raise your hand if you have a question
and and just say who you are keep the
questions brief if you're in one of the
other rooms you can actually tweet a
question it s G at Yale and well-well do
our best to read them and as you guys
are thinking up questions I'll start
with one which is the last seven years
have been focused on the policy of
healthcare and and the wiring and the
payments and coverage how do we shift
the conversation at a federal state good
question ultimately there has been a
great deal of focus on policy with the
passage of the Affordable Care Act with
the implementation of the law as well as
with other policy provisions that have
been very important but we cannot let
that obscure and as important as these
policy provisions are is the fact that
health is ultimately determined and
driven by what happens in communities
and if communities don't feel like they
are partners in creating better health
then we can never get to where we need
to be so that means that we have to go
to communities and engage teachers and
schools that we have to engage not only
educators but CEOs and employees and
businesses that we have engaged faith
leaders and others and help them see the
role that they can play in improving
health what is interesting to me as I
travel around the country and talk to
sectors that are not traditionally
engaged in health is that many of them
are deeply affected by and concerned by
the health challenges that we face many
of them know for example that if they
are running a business and their
employees are saddled with chronic
illnesses and missing work a lot that
that affects their bottom line
it affects morale at work it affects a
business that they're trying to build
faith leaders who are ultimately looking
out for the well-being of their
congregation to realize that mental
illness is a great burden for so many of
the families in their community in part
because many people don't feel
comfortable addressing mental illness
because of the stigma solicitous
with it so non health related community
leaders understand this but what they
often don't know is what role they can
play in helping to change that reality
on the ground and that's where I believe
we have to shift and increase our focus
as public health leaders because if you
think about public health and jobs in
public health as those which are solely
limited to researching specific program
programs and working at a desk in a
department of public health those are
very very important roles
we can't lose those we have to in fact
strengthen those roles but if you think
that public health is only those things
then I think we we have missed the boat
because what we have to realize is that
public health now has to become a
convening role is that public health has
to be the force that enables people to
see that health is the thread that runs
through everything we do and so the
question of who is gonna bring employers
and faith leaders and the YMCA's and and
others together to actually work on
prevention initiatives I think that the
answer is public health leaders have to
do that so that's why I would love to
see more of our students faculty members
public health experts out in communities
helping to build these initiatives
helping to teach people about the role
that they can play and then helping to
work with them to build collaborations
that make that a reality that's the role
that we need and I will tell you from
seeing examples of death around the
country that when it happens that
communities benefit and the different
partners are usually very grateful and
so one of the initiatives we're trying
to build right now is a collaboration
with faith leaders around mental health
we're also working with employers around
physical activity will be working with
employers on nutrition as well there are
people out there who are active and
willing and ready to play a role in
improving health but they are waiting
for your call they're waiting for your
direction and waiting for your guidance
and that's where I think the future of
public health lies so questions
I had a good question regarding that
kind of fatalistic mentality that you
mentioned early in your in your
conversation so it disproportionately
minority communities or communities of
color have this fatalistic mentality in
terms of their health how is the Surgeon
General's Office engaging with other
players and stakeholders to address the
needs of these particular communities
it's it's a good point what issue you
bring up is really the issue of health
equity and the idea that we still
experience great inequities when it
comes to health where certain
communities are saddled with more of a
burden than others and have
disproportionate rates of illness
disproportionate access to treatment or
lack of access to treatment in some
cases part of what our office is doing
is to make health equity a cornerstone
of each of our campaigns so you'll
notice for example in the call to action
that we put out on walking and it wasn't
just telling people to walk but very
deliberately the focus of our report was
walking and walkable communities
recognizing that many communities
particular communities of color as well
as folks who are living with
disabilities I do not have access to do
something as basic as walking to do in a
safe you know and you know and
reasonable way in their neighborhoods
and I realized this actually early on
because I remember I'm caring for
patients up in Boston and Brigham
Women's Hospital who we would often say
you tell you know to take walks you know
as a way to just help burn some calories
and get active if they were dealing with
obesity or they're looking to prevent
illness I remember one patient in
particular you know we shared this
advice with because she had I dealt with
obesity for a long time and developed
diabetes had a lot of chronic
complications thereafter and what people
didn't realize until later is it for her
going for a walk outside was really the
choice between getting exercise or
taking their risk of getting mugged or
shot and when you face that kind of
choice then it's it's not an easy
decision I mean it's not a hard decision
to make really you you know you choose
your safety over the what you perceive
as a short-term benefit of your
so our office is making health equity a
cornerstone of each of our campaigns but
there's something else I think that we
have to do collectively which is that we
need to ensure that there are more
leaders from communities of color who
are stepping into public health roles
who are represented in our workforce the
diversity of our workforce should
reflect the diversity of the patients
and the community members we are seeking
to serve that makes a very very very big
difference and I'll tell you just a
personal anecdote that Alice and I were
just dealing with though this weekend
you know we had a friend who called us
from New York and you know she said you
know this is essentially like my sister
her her her good friend his mother had
been admitted to the hospital
with bleeding from the gastrointestinal
tract and as some of you may know your
blood counts are typically checked or
tracked by hemoglobin or hematocrit you
know a good hemoglobin might be
somewhere in the range of 12 to 15
depending on if you're a man or a woman
her hemoglobin 2 days prior to admission
was was 10 then she felt unwell went to
the hospital it was a recheck just 48
hours later and her hemoglobin had
fallen to 7 then was rechecked again
when they were concerned that she was
really bleeding a few hours later her
hemoglobin had dropped to 5 this is an
extraordinarily low level and so as a
physician a nurse is a health care
provider your immediate thought is how
do I get blood into my patient because
in the short term that's what they need
they need fluids and I you know I but
ideally blood but even despite the fact
that she was facing imminent death me as
the bleeding was continuing she didn't
want to get blood in fact she didn't
want IV fluids in fact you didn't even
want an IV and when we asked why it
turned out that she didn't trust the
people who were taking care of her not
because they had done anything wrong but
because she was african-american and she
felt that her community had been wronged
many times in the past and taken
advantage of by the medical and public
systems and she didn't know what was
going on and what they were trying to do
to her she wasn't worried that they were
just trying to get her into surgery so
they could make money but distrust was
at the root of that and it took somebody
coming in who said very very much
similar things but who understood her
background who understood her
experiences who came from her community
it tooks a messenger like that actually
convinced her that it was important for
her to get the blood and eventually she
did and she responded well to it but
this is just one example of how the
diversity of our workforce has an
important impact on the treatment that
were ultimately able to deliver because
the best of science and practice is
sometimes insufficient to overcome
barriers of trust and diversity matters
there thank you dr. murti my question is
on under vaccinations in America
particularly in California where
relatively the children in public and
private schools are compared to the rest
of the country are under vaccinated and
UC exemptions are much higher rates than
other parts of the country and so while
I believe education is a long-term good
thing that we should do I guess from
your experience traveling across the
country and talking to people what are
the biggest short-term and long-term
challenges to raising vaccination rates
the approaches that you think can
address them and I guess how can we
approach people who are generally good
people that have concerns about
vaccinating their kids and the tension
underlying tension about individual
liberty and social good that you know
centers around this debate it's a good
question the vaccine debate is an
important one because it actually has
implications from many other topics that
we're discussing as a country where we
wrestle with this where the line between
individual liberties and collective
responsibility comes in but I will say
when it comes to that line there
we have made a decision in many other
cases that we value collective good over
individual decision-making especially in
cases or individual decisions affect the
community and that is the case with
vaccinations that we know when a family
makes a decision not to vaccinate their
child that they are not just putting
their child at risk but they are putting
other children at risk around them and
take measles for example we know that
even that some people who get the
measles vaccine just don't respond to it
the measles vaccine if you get both
doses of it confers a 97% protection
rate but there are three percent of
people who will still be vulnerable if
they're exposed to measles through no
wrongdoing of their own there are also
people who may have can be compromised
immune systems who cannot get vaccinated
and who are also vulnerable to being
into exposure these people rely on us to
ensure that we are vaccinated so that we
protect them as well one of the most
important things we can do to improve
vaccination rates is to raise our voice
as public health professionals because
one of the biggest problems we have is
that the volume of our voices is way too
low like who our policymakers hearing
from when it comes to making decisions
on vaccines I don't think they're
usually hearing from public health
professionals who are dialing in to
their office and keeping their phone's
off the hook with the importance and
urgency of Public Health in fact far too
often I find that medical and public
health professionals don't think that
they can have a real impact on policy
decisions so just out of curiosity how
many people here have ever called an
elected leader to share an opinion a
member of Congress the state legislature
okay so maybe about a quarter of people
here so that's good and I'm glad that
you have next time I come back to campus
I would love if everyone Razer
and the reason is because legislators
need to hear from you some people when
you read the paper you sometimes think
well legislators and folks in DC or in
state houses that they're just very you
know they're politicians are very
calculating they don't really care about
like the impact they're thinking about
political decisions I have found that is
not the case many I've had the great
privilege of working with and meeting
with many elected leaders and what I
find as many of them are there because
they wanted to improve health for the
community they understand politics and
have to contend with it but a lot of
times they also don't have information
about what the public they have public
health the implications are of policy
options that are on the table
and that's where you come in you know
you can be a powerful force for
education the work that I did before I
came to this office was centered around
mobilizing physicians to be educators to
be leaders in sharing public health
messages with with elected leaders and
each and every time they did that they
were received warmly because people even
didn't hear very often from public
health professionals so I think that
that's a powerful thing that we can do
to help improve policy around this I
think what you saw in California will
you've seen in states across the
countries and more and more states
re-examining their exemption laws
they're looking at how to strike that
balance between individual liberty and
public health but in a way that does
does not do a disservice to those folks
who are vulnerable California was able
to strengthen its laws and other states
are looking to do the same but we can
accelerate progress on this by having
more public health leaders to speak up
and call their elected officials to
reveal I'm gonna actually ask you a
question from Twitter from from the pulp
operetta and Carmen Sandiego
silly silly names but good questions and
and what they're trying to ask is you
know outside of health what role do
public health professionals play in
areas like climate change and gun
and radicular mortality with how wide is
the net we should cast the net is wide
because all of those things actually
involve health climate change has health
impacts gun violence has health impacts
there are so many things which housing
has an impact on health the kind of
transportation that's available in your
community has an impact on whether
people are physically active or not and
whether they're safe or not something
it's especially important at a time
where we lose nearly 5,000 people like a
year due to pedestrian accidents and
injure nearly over 66,000 more so all of
these things we don't traditionally
think of as being related to health but
they are and that's actually why the net
for public health professionals of this
generation and future generations has to
be wide now when you initially go out
there there are people who say stay in
your lane don't focus on issues that are
not public health related and that's why
it's your responsibility and our
collective responsibility is public
health leaders to help people to see
that our lane is wide so wide in fact
that it encompasses most other lanes and
that's why we have to be conveners and
coordinators in helping other sectors
understand how they can work together
with us to improve our public health
broadly because lastly I'll say this
there's a certain amount of things that
we can do like in you know in our
clinics and hospitals there are certain
things that we can do through our public
health programs but the amount of
benefit that we can get if we for
example move towards smoke-free housing
the amount of benefit that we can get if
we build and plan cities in ways that
make physical activity easier and
actually more enjoyable the amount of
game that we can get if we work with
employers to make small changes in the
workplace which can improve and improve
a nutrition and physical activity these
are big big gains and this is where I
think the big gains are in public health
that we need to go after another
question
hi thank you so much for your talk
I seem to be
but also feeling I was at the same time
well it's a good question and thank you
for your comment as well the question of
how to restore a sense of power and
agency to individuals when it comes to
health is the great challenge that faces
our country right now I believe it's
bigger than the challenge we face in any
individual disease group because if we
can if we can enable people to reconnect
with their power and with their sense of
agency then they can do extraordinary
things in their community the place
where you can start often is as I
mentioned earlier by sharing your
opinions and your ideas and your
observations with elected leaders but
when you're facing big forces the
industry that you think may not listen
to you that's where the power of
collective will comes in and that's why
we have the power even though we may
think that were one individual what can
we do the thing that you have to
remember is you're not just one
individual but for every person who
speaks up about it issue about an issue
there often many more who are out there
who feel the same thing and who are
looking for a leader who will bring them
together to be enable them to raise
their collective voices and you can be
that leader when I was 17 years old my
sister and I began our first nonprofit
organization we were a freshman in
college we'd no clue really what we were
doing but we were excited about the and
about the idea of addressing HIV which
we saw as a growing problem at that time
in India and certainly of course in the
United States we didn't really know what
we were doing but we were excited by the
possibility of creating some change we
knew we couldn't do it alone
so we brought a few folks together who
understood what we were trying to do who
shared similar values they were students
like us and what enabled us to build an
operation that ultimately educated tens
of thousands of students and that
changed the career trajectories of many
folks along the way
what enabled us to do that was building
collective will was bringing people
together was recognizing that we don't
have to be sole actors in life but that
our role can be conveners and that by
doing so it's not only good for the
community but we give other people who
are often struggling with a sense you
know of disempowerment we give them an
opportunity to step up and make it
friends as well so those are the kind of
leaders that I think you need to be
that's the power of what you can create
through collective will and when you do
that history tells us time and time
again that small groups of passionate
people who believe in what they're doing
and are not willing to give up can
overcome extraordinary obstacles and can
create incredible change that's the
history of our country that's the legacy
of public health that's a legacy that
you are moving forward and that's why I
think that's what's gonna enable us I
believe to create this golden era public
health that we really need final
question will pass the microphone over
to you in answering a lot of your
questions you spoke a lot about like
historic wrongdoings and the mistrust
that that builds within communities and
you've also spoken about issues of
neglect issues of access to safe
communities to health facilities but how
do we address issues that are not just
historic and not just passive but
actually active I'm thinking about
issues of police violence in communities
of color I'm thinking about issues of
HIV criminalization to what extent can
the state address these issues within
themselves and how can we assist as
public health students as public health
professionals in kind of guiding away
from these policies that actively
produce negative health outcomes what I
would say is that you don't need to just
assist this date but you need to lead
this day in doing that you think about
violence and communities right there are
measures that citizens can take to work
with law enforcement to build safer
communities there are dialogues that
citizens coming together can actually
start with law enforcement about how to
create better relationships you know
between the residents of the
neighborhoods and those who are trying
to keep it safe we can start these
dialogues they don't require an act of
Congress they don't require legislation
nobody needs to give us as public health
leaders permission to start dialogues
but that is the power of what you can do
because there's a danger here when we
look at
some of these issues as they're covered
because the way that issues like police
violence and others get covered are such
that we sometimes see the most extreme
cases but we can also generalize too
easily and assume that every person
believes what the worst possible person
out there believes we can believe that
every law enforcement officer out there
it doesn't care about minorities and
it's looking to use excessive force that
is not true there are many many law
enforcement officials in this country
who wake up and go to work every day
with the best of intentions who do their
jobs well and many who come from
communities of color that have been
affected so we have to be careful about
generalizing and we have to what if we
do if we are careful about that that
also gives us the opportunity to partner
with people who are doing it right to
hold them up as examples of how doing
this the right way of policing
communities of partner with communities
is possible it's not just theoretical
because if you think about what we
elevate in our public discourse we tend
to elevate what is wrong we tell it to
tend to elevate the examples that depict
our failings what we can do as public
health leaders is to elevate the
examples of where we get it right we can
elevate those voices and we can
strengthen the dialogue that takes place
between the folks who are getting it
right and their communities and that's
where I think we can be leaders in it it
could be something as simple as as a
public health leader convening a town
hall meeting with law enforcement and
members of the community could be
something as simple as sitting down with
law enforcement as a public health
leader to talk about the problems that
understand what law enforcement in your
community is doing I like to try to
address you know the concerns of the
community everything starts often with
this simple step
that's what Lao Tzu said right he said
the journey of a thousand miles begins
with a single step and that's what as
public health leaders we can do is take
that step and when we take that step
then we we not only make prep to where
progress but we give other people
permission to take a step as well that's
what leadership is about and that's what
I think you can do as well
what would an extraordinary way to end
so I think that all that's left is
thanking you for for an amazing talk and
amazing inspiration and and for joining
us so can we join me